all right welcome back to the third
lecture today
given by jalani nielsen jalani is a
computer scientist at uc berkeley
specializing in
streaming algorithms and dimensional
reduction he's also a
organizer of this program he will be
lecturing about
sketching high dimensional data so now
let's turn it over to july 4th first
lecture
sure all right so as you said i'm going
to be talking about sketching
high dimensional data as the title of my
crash course
um and also for those of you who are
long-term participants
um i am actually teaching a graduate
course this semester here
um on sketching algorithms and i'm happy
to have auditors sit in the course so
that's
just contact me separately after this if
you're interested that's cs
294-165
i can send you the zoom link for that
okay um so good so
what is sketching first of all so a
sketch
is just compression
of data in our case some
high dimensional vectors
or it might be one vector
to allow for you know later
querying about the data
um and there are a few models maybe to
keep in mind
um so there are scenarios
so one is the following there are a
bunch of different
parties that each hold some high
dimensional input
so let's say here um each x i
is some high dimensional vector
and there's some central compute node
here who i'll call the referee
and each one of these parties sends
something to that referee who then has
to
send some output it has to compute some
output
and what do they send they send their
sketches these compressed
representations of their inputs
and there may be some
[Music]
shared randomness here
some shared random string in the sky
that they can all look at
in helping them compute their sketches
this is a model that's usually called
simultaneous sketching
so this is a scenario one
um another scenario we're going to focus
on is what's called the streaming model
so here we have you know some this
vector x this just one vector now
jalani i just there there is a bunch of
stuff that is
under the bottom of our screen on mine i
don't know if other people have the same
problem like there's an arrow that says
simultaneous sketching in blue and
whatever is under there i can't see
oh yeah sorry there's nothing under
there oh okay that's the end
yeah um so in the other scenario there's
some
um some high dimensional vector x
there's only one such vector
and it starts out say the zero vector
and we see a sequence of updates
so you know some x1 want to add some
amount of some amount to x1 x1 gets x1
plus 7
x2 gets to be x2 minus 5
and then maybe i can update x1 again
and then someone then asks some query
and then i have to output the answer to
that query
and again what i want to store is a
sketch which is a compression
um so never am i actually storing this
n dimensional vector i'm storing some
compressed representation of it
and this is called the uh this scenario
is usually referred to as the turn style
streaming model
and the other scenario which i'm not
going to draw is just um
kind of offline computation so i have
some
problem that i want to solve offline on
some huge dimensional data
and um
i want you know maybe to speed up it's
not necessarily about
um using low memory or having small
message lengths as in the
simultaneous sketching scenario right in
simultaneous sketching the real goal
here is
minimize communication because each one
of these parties is sending a message to
referee you want these messages to be to
be short
these are the short compressions in the
turn style streaming model
you know you're computing something on x
and your goal really here is to use low
memory
because you could just store x
explicitly in memory
and and keep all these updates exactly
but
if you if you process this if you if you
only ever store a sketch of x
and whenever you receive updates you
update the sketch then you have a low
memory algorithm
the third scenario which i won't draw is
completely offline
is offline computation you just have
some high dimensional
inputs and you want to compute something
like find me a good clustering or solve
some regression problem
um and the goal there is you know if i
can if i can maybe compress
to some lower dimensional representation
then the algorithms that i'm going to
run later are faster
okay so that's the just offline
computation that's the third scenario
so let me continue
kind of you know a simple simple example
really simple example just to make sure
we're all on the same page
not everything will start off
complicated is uh maybe two simple
examples
i see a stream
of you know transactions
like sales i'm a website that sells
stuff
and i want to know
maybe one you know maybe my gross sales
for the day or two
you know just how many transactions were
there
okay so these are these are very simple
things to solve you know i don't need to
um i don't need to store the full
sequence of transactions i can just
store a compressed representation which
is a single number
a counter right so whenever there's a
new transaction i add to the gross sales
and i
increment the number of transactions so
i can hear you know the simple counter
for both of these
but already you know even here for this
simple example
um you can actually ask whether you can
do better so for example here
if i get if if we get up to like end
transactions
naively you would need
um log n bits for that counter
right but if you don't want to know the
number of transactions exactly if you're
satisfied with
keeping track of these numbers with very
small error like i just want to make
sure i know the number of transactions
up to maybe one percent error or one
plus epsilon multiplicative error
if i only want to know these
item two would say one plus epsilon
multiplicative error
then i did i could hope to do better
because you know
let's just write down all the powers of
one plus epsilon
between one and n
as long as i remember which power of one
plus epsilon is closest to n
um that's you know i can just return
that power
and i can use low memory because i only
need to remember the power how many
powers are there
there are log plus one log base one plus
epsilon of n
which is approximately the same thing as
one over epsilon log n
powers of one plus epsilon each one and
one and n so if i want to remember which
one is the close one
i just need log of that number in bits
all right and that and that is basically
uh
log one over epsilon plus log log n
right so instead of login bits i'm only
using log log n bits
so you know that's that's kind of the
best i could hope to do
and um it turns out and i'm not gonna
you know
it's gonna develop a little bit i'm not
gonna actually go into the algorithm but
just to show you that even for these
very simple problems you can do not real
stuff
it turns out that you can actually
achieve this in a streaming fashion
right so if i just go back for a second
this is saying that if i knew ahead of
time what n was
i could just remember i can just
remember the exponent of one plus
epsilon that's close that that gives me
the
the power that's closest to it but of
course in a streaming fashion
i don't know the future i don't know
what n is going to end up at
all i see are you know transactions
after
transaction after transaction so
basically it's increment increment
increment end times
but in the middle of all these
increments i don't know what the final
and will be
so when how do i decide when to
increment the power one plus epsilon how
do i decide when the exponent should
change that's not
clear it's not obvious but it turns out
there is a way to
to handle this um and
kind of the optimal bound is as follows
so for all epsilon and delta
in 0 1
you know can compute
some estimate n hat such that the
probability
that n hat minus n is bigger than
epsilon times
n is at most delta and then the amount
of space you use
is using o of log one over epsilon
plus log log n plus log log
one over delta bits of memory okay
um and
this is optimal
to be more precise the min of this
expression
and log n is optimal log n is the
trivial just maintaining a counter
um so at some point you know um if you
want really really really low failure
probability
then you might as well just maintain uh
maintain a deterministic counter but up
until that point
there is an algorithm that gets you this
kind of log one of some plus log log n
behavior with this additive log log one
over delta or delta's the failure
probability
um and this is actually due to
robert morris in 1978 as well as
myself and watching you that's very
recent well
21 i guess we submitted to something
that would be in 21.
so morris basically got this without the
log log whatever delta it used to be log
when over delta
but what we could show is that in fact
the iterated logarithm is the right
answer
um both the upper and lower bound so
already there's non-trivial stuff that
you know can happen for very simple
problems
um so i want to move into another
problem that
fits into the turnstile streaming model
for today
and i'm going to use that as just an
example problem to
to show you some common techniques that
are used in the design of algorithms
and i also want to show you um lower
down so i want to prove a lower bound
for you to show you that you know
sketches have to be at least a certain
length to solve certain problems
um okay or rather
can't be solved with sketching yes
question there's a question maybe what's
clarifying because
uh daniel is asking about the model here
is this after some t-turn style steps
sorry what was the question again what's
the model here is this after some t-turn
style steps
oh for this theorem yeah so the model
the model here
for this particular thing um
you know you can imagine so here's the
problem right so the problem is
maintain a counter
c subject to
three operations one let's say init
just you know sets the counter to zero
to
increment
increments the counter and three is
query
and this should return let's say an
approximation
uh an approximation to the counter
okay so so yeah just
think of it as a as a data structural
problem the data structure has to
maintain this counter
c um well maybe i should have called it
n maintain the counter n subject to
initialization increment and query and
what i'm saying is there is an
algorithm that can do this it can give
you an estimate so
n hat is basically the answer to query
it's your estimate of the counter
such that with high probability your
estimate will be close to the truth
and you use you know much less space
than just using a deterministic counter
right but uh john does that answer the
question
yeah uh but the question is like is
is this probability bound like you know
uh the
first time you query or if you can you
query infinitely many times
or you you know because it's uh it's for
each query
okay so for each query you have for any
fixed query you have some probability of
error and this is what it is
that's right yes okay okay
okay good so let's continue and unless
are there any other questions
okay okay very good so
today i'm going to focus on
um a problem called the distinct
elements problem
okay so here we have again we have this
vector and this is going to be in the
turnstile streaming model
so we have this x which is an n
dimensional vector it starts as the zero
vector
and i'm going to imagine that you know
update
i just increments x i
okay and then when someone says query
we have to output the support size
of the vector okay
in other words we see a stream of
numbers
and we have to output you know the
number of distinct
numbers in the sequence so here the
answer
would be i guess so one is distinct so
it's five seven we've already seen five
and seven and two so here the answer
would be four
okay
um so these these
these numbers that i've circled these
are just the indices i that got updated
right
okay so you know the
there are i'd say the trivial algorithm
is just you know maintain
a bit vector
of length n where the ith bit is one if
you've ever seen item i
so this would use n bits of memory
but we want to we want to do something
that's much better than that okay
so we're going to do in fact
exponentially better
so first i'm going to show you an
idealized algorithm
and this is due to flagellate
and martin in the 80s
maybe it was 85 or 82 i'm forgetting but
i'll just say the 1980s
okay and the idea is as follows
okay so first of all why is it idealized
so
step one
i'm going to so let's say actually let
me actually um
versus the initialization phase i'll say
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pick a random hash function
mapping the universe remember this is an
n-dimensional vector in other words all
the numbers i see are integers between 1
and n in the stream
i'm going to map that universe into the
continuous interval from 0 to 1. and i'm
also
going to pick um well initialize this
one number x
to the number one
okay um and then when i see update
so when i see the number i in the stream
what i'm going to do is i'm going to set
x
to be the min of what it was before
and h of i
and then query
i'm just going to return
1 over x minus 1.
okay so this is the idealized algorithm
why is it idealized
um a couple of reasons one you know
there's this there's this random
function h
okay which is a sequence of n numbers to
specify
h so naively i would have to store h in
memory and that's using
n you know n numbers in memory so i
there's already an n-bit solution to
this problem so why why would i bother
with an algorithm that needs to store n
real numbers that's even worse than n
bits
um another reason it's idealized again
is because i'm storing real numbers and
not bits right so
i'm storing these h of i's but
um h of i is a real number between zero
and one my computer has finite precision
it can't store real numbers
but you know that that can be well we'll
un-idealize this algorithm later
i'll give a non-idealized version
okay but you know if you ignore all that
stuff
instead of storing n bits i'm storing
one number right the only thing i'm
storing in my memory
other than h is x x is one number
so that's some hope that you know
this is sort of low memory some way of
thinking of this sort of little memory
so what's going on here
so the idea
is you know if
there are two distinct
integers in the stream
in other words you know the support size
of this underlying vector x is t
then x is the minimum
of t iid uniform
random variables uh in the interval zero
one right
and what do i expect well you know
here's zero here's one
you know if basically i expect these t
random numbers to be
evenly distributed on the line
so that means these gaps would be one
over t plus one this is just you know
simple order statistics so i
expect the minimum number here to be one
over t plus one
right so i'm i'm returning
one over x minus one which you know i'm
hoping is going to be
1 over kind of 1 over t plus 1 minus 1
which i'm hoping to be you know t
right so so that's where this is coming
from hopefully that makes sense
and indeed you can you know you can
you know actually i have a question yes
do you have to store the hedging
function
h in this case do you have to store h
d do you you have to right you do have
those i mean the reason you have to
store
it so why do you have to store h the pro
the point is if you see one
five seven five whatever
you know you have to compute h's of all
these right
and store the minimum and the point is
when you see five for the second time
the random number you spit out had
better be the same random number as you
spit out for the previous five
otherwise otherwise it's not going to be
the minimum of t uh id random variables
it's going to be the minimum
it's going to be the minimum of you know
the length of the sequence random
variables
but when you talk about the memory cost
you didn't take into account of the cost
for h right right yeah so that's one of
the two reasons i said it's idealized oh
okay
because i pretended that i could store
each for free somehow
and the other and the other is that you
know these are real numbers and my
computer
i usually measure membrane bits i can't
store real numbers
i think the latter is easier to solve
the latter you basically just kind of
you know round to some finite precision
and say that it still works
but the business of how you know how do
you store h that is a real issue
but in this idealized world i'm
pretending that h is free
okay any other questions
so how would you analyze something like
this
so you just do some order statistics you
would say look the expectation
one you prove that the expectation of x
is one over t
plus one okay
um right
and let me not spend too much time on it
but the point is this thing
you know x is the minimum
of i'll just call them x1 up to xt these
are these id uniform random variables so
this is just simple order statistics
right so the expectation of
x is the integral of the probability
that x is bigger than lambda d lambda
right and kind of x can never be bigger
than 1 because all these random
variables are uniform in 0 1.
um and what's the probability that x is
bigger than lambda
um this is
so remember x is the minimum so for that
for it to be bigger than lambda it must
be the case that
you know that for all i x i is bigger
than lambda
right and what's that and these are
independent random variables
so what's this probability this is well
remember x i is uniform from 0 to 1
if it's bigger than lambda it must be in
the interval from lambda to one
that's a sub interval of length one
minus lambda so this has probability one
minus lambda
to the t because there are t of them so
you just integrate this
one minus lambda to the t from zero to
one you get exactly what i said you get
one over t equals one
and two you could similarly compute
variances
and say the variance of x
is equal to the precise expression is
t over t plus one squared times t
plus two but you know the point all i
really care about is that it's less than
[Music]
one over t plus one squared which is
just you know the same thing as uh
the expectation of x squared by the way
okay
all right good so we have a bound on the
expectation we haven't we well not a
bound we've computed the expectation
we have some good band on the variance
now how do you turn this into
an algorithm and and this business of
you know showing how to come up with an
unbiased
i mean why am i focusing on distinct
elements right now it's that there's
kind of a formula for designing
not all algorithms follow the formula
many don't but
this is a formula a recipe for designing
algorithms
that is often used which is that you
figure out how to come up with
you know some random process and
associated estimator such that that is
that estimator is unbiased and it has
bounded variance
and then you can turn that and then you
know the random process what you need
from it can be
stored in low memory and then you can
turn that into
an algorithm a low memory algorithm in
the way that i'm about to describe to
you right now
okay so let's continue um
so you know what i just described
is this flagellae martin algorithm so
now let me show you an algorithm that
i'll call fledgling martin plus
which is as follows
instantiate
r independent copies
of flashlight martin
and when i see update i
um feed
this update to each copy
and then when i say query
so let's say each copy of fm
gives um you know store some counter
let me write it like this actually so
each let's say fmi
stores some counter
x i so what i'll do is i'll output
um 1 over so before was 1 over x minus 1
okay so i'm not going to do 1 over x
minus 1. so my new x is going to be the
average of all the x i's
so this is going to be 1 over r sum of x
i i goes from 1 to r and this minus 1.
right and the reason i'm doing this is
if i just do one cop
one instantiation of the algorithm fm
then you know that x yes it's unbiased
but it has some variance and the
variance isn't so great that it's you
know tightly concentrated
but if i run many copies and average
them then this thing
is going to be more tightly concentrated
around its expectation which i said was
one over t plus one
okay and i can just yes
question yeah wouldn't i mean would the
median also work here
or would that be a bad idea um would the
median work in this case
um
i could probably concoct uh examples
where
if you just did what i did with the
median um
it wouldn't work but um
certainly if you did the median here it
wouldn't work via the argument i'm about
to show you
there might you might you might be able
to you know design some taylor
argument that that would make it work
but i will use the median shortly just
not right at this moment
so i didn't answer your question because
i don't i don't know offhand
whether or not it would work for sure
but this but this definitely does work
any other questions
okay um good
so what's going on here so let's let's
see let's this is my let's call this x
so what do i have i have that
the expectation of x is just as what it
was before t plus 1
and the variance of x
is now less than you know it used to be
less than it used to be at most one over
t plus one squared now it's less than
one over r
times one over t plus one squared
just because i averaged r copies
so um the probability now that x
and in fact yeah good it's good good so
the probability
that um x minus
one over t plus one which is its
expectation is bigger than
epsilon over t plus one
is at most
um t plus 1 squared
over epsilon squared
times the variance of x this is just
chebyshev's inequality
uh which is i said less than t plus 1
squared
over epsilon squared times 1 over r
times 1 over t plus 1 squared
and then this cancels this and i can
make sure
that this thing is less than or equal to
delta
if i just set r here
r to be set you know set r to be
basically whatever epsilon squared delta
in fact let me not i want to use delta
for something else later so let me not
make this delta i'm going to make this
be uh let's say ada
okay so this is
then you know so this is all part of the
recipe and album design right so i
started off
just having something that was an
unbiased estimator with some bound on
its variance
i plused it which meant taking a bunch
of independent copies and averaging them
to get the variance down
um so that i get i get my one plus
epsilon approximation with failure
probability at most eta
but i paid i paid by multiplying my
memory cost
by this factor of r right because i'm
writing the algorithm r times in
parallel
so whatever my old memory requirement
was it's now r times larger
and r depends on epsilon and eta in this
way this one over epsilon squared times
one over eta
so now i'm going to show you how to get
a better dependence on eta which is
going to use the median
i'll call this fm plus plus
and what i'll do is i'll run
you know s independent copies
of this other algorithm fm plus
on the previous whiteboard each
with um eta being equal to say
a third so with a constant eta
and you know
when i say when i have an update
see i'll feed the update to each
fm plus copy and when i have a query
now what i'll do is i'll let's say i'll
you know a query
i'll query each let's call it fm
plus sub i so each of the copies of the
fm plus
to get some to get some estimate of t
and that estimate i'll call t i tilde
so fm plus i is giving me some estimate
of t which i'll call ti
tilde what i'll output
is the median
over all of these of ti tilde
okay so here's where i'll use the median
okay and you know this is this is all
kind of standard stuff uh in in the in
the design of these kinds of algorithms
and why do why do we do this why do we
do this median of means
um and it's to get the it's to get
better dependence on the failure
probability
and ultimately it's you know why is that
happening it's because of the turn off
bound
so the observation here
is that as long
as at least half
of the fm ia or sorry
fm plus i's
you have a good approximation a one plus
epsilon approximation
to t to t which i'll just call this is
just succeeding
right then the median
will also succeed it'll be a good
approximation
so the expected number of copies
that fail right well remember now each
one fails with probability eta
so just by linear expectation the
expected number that fail
is eta times s
and eta was a third so this is s over
three
right so you expect at most s over three
copies to fail
and your output will be good as long as
at most half fail right
so you know in order for you in order
for you to fail
this number here has to deviate from its
expectation
by s over two minus s over three which
is s over six
right it has to deviate from its
expectation by s over six
and the probability of that happening by
the turn off bound because these
these fm pluses are independent copies
the probability that happening is at
most exponentially small
in s e to the minus some constant times
s
so as long as i pick s to be
some constant times log
of 1 over delta
then i'm good right
then that's a that's a very low
probability of n the probability of that
happening is at most delta
so overall
overall uh over here overall
space blow up
to get one plus epsilon approximation
is r times s which is o
of log one over delta over epsilon
squared
so whatever the memory cost of one basic
estimator is
that gets multiplied by this and then i
can get a one plus epsilon approximation
with probability one minus delta
okay so this is a very just common
recipe um
in the design of these things so any
questions about this i mean
yes it's idealized for the reasons i
said so i wanna i wanna talk about how
to make it not idealized
and then we can talk about kind of
proving
some lower bounds so
questions
okay
so next
make algorithm you know not be idealized
okay
now there is an algorithm that um
is when i make it when i make it be
kind of a real algorithm and not
idealize anymore um i am going to
actually change i'm not just going to
show you how to get this magic h i'm
actually going to change the algorithm a
bit
there is an algorithm that stays
somewhat close to the algorithm i just
showed you
which is not idealized but i'm going to
show you a different algorithm
that's not idealized because it also it
also will
show you another kind of common design
tactic in you know in this
in this space of algorithm design okay
so here's a non-idealized algorithm and
it's a simplification
of algorithm number three in a paper
by um barrios
jram
kumar shiva kumar
and trevison in 2002
and here's the idea okay so
first of all i know that you know
everyone in this call is coming from
different backgrounds
some of us are theoretical computer
scientists some of us
you know are in statistics for
mathematics and maybe
we don't all have exactly the same
language so
before i show the algorithm i want to
make sure that there is something that
we all
do know about which is uh something that
comes from pseudorandomness
so pseudo randomness is an important
concept in the design of streaming
algorithms the idea here is
you know i have some idealized algorithm
which assumes perfect randomness
but for one reason or another i don't
you know i don't want to assume that i
have this perfect randomness um
in our case the reason is that you know
what we have you know where is that
perfect random is it's this perfect hash
function h
which maps the universe into the
interval from zero to one
um you know i don't want to assume that
i'm using that because it's very
expensive memory wise to store such a
function
so what i would like is not a function
that's totally random like that h
but a function that is you know
pseudorandom
it's you know it's it's it's uh it has
much less entropy
than a truly uniformly random function h
and you know small enough in fact it's
entropy is so small that i can store it
in memory
instead of n bits i can store it in log
n bits or something uh even though it's
mapping this universe of size n into
sides of this range
okay but you know even though it's not
perfectly random
it's random enough whatever that means
okay we'll see what
what that could mean it's random enough
that if i were to use it in my algorithm
my algorithm would still work okay
um so that's that's what we're going to
be interested in when we talk about
pseudorandomness
it's replacing these idealized you know
perfectly random hash functions with
other things that are random enough that
the album still works while being
storable in memory using like
exponentially less memory
yeah and
we're going to talk specifically about
ky's independent hash families
right so a hash family
hash family
h is just a set
of functions
you know mapping
mapping some domain to some range
yeah when i do this i mean
the integers one up to n into some range
and what does it mean because
independent
h is k y's
independent okay so this is
the term i care about if
um for all
x1 not equal to x2 not equal to that not
equal to xk
in in the domain and for all y1 up to yk
in the range
the probability that for all i
so h the probability is now h is is
picked randomly from this family
right so capital script h is a big
collection it's a set of hash
a set of functions i'm picking a random
function from the set of functions
and the probabilities over that that for
all i
h of x i equals y i
this should be the same as if i had
actually picked a totally uniformly
random function from the set of all
functions
and that would give you something like 1
over m to the k
um and you know there are variants on
this there's you know this concept of
like almost ky's independence
um where you don't care that it's
exactly one over m to the k
but there's a lot to be some some
bounded error there etc
i'm not going to get into all of that
but let me just give an example
so right if i have h script h is you
know the set
of all functions
mapping and into m
this is k y's independent basically for
all k right
what's the downside the downside is to
store
storing a function from the set
takes log base two of the set size bits
which in this case is what it's um
n times log n
what i would like is i would like um
i would like a set of functions that's
ky's independent for some k that you
know suffices for the analysis of my
algorithm
which is small i want script h to be
small so that
picking an element a function from this
set of functions
can be can be represented in much fewer
bits than this
so the classical example
is um you know polynomial hashing
which is i imagine say n equals m
equals q which is a prime power
and then h is the set of all functions
um
h of x is equal to the sum
a i x to the i where i goes from 0 to k
minus 1
where a 1 up to a k minus 1 are all in f
cubed
it follows from polynomial interpolation
that this thing is ky's independent
okay it satisfies the property that of
the definition that i showed you in the
previous whiteboard
and here the size of h
is what basically you just have to tell
you know to specify a little h
you just have to tell me what the
coefficients are of this polynomial
so that's q to the k so that implies
that
i can store h in k log q
which is you know basically k log n
bits
so you can imagine you know if your
algorithm only requires
two wise independence then or you know
some constant k
then i can get away with representing my
my function my random function using
only o of log n bits
okay so i know for for many of you
you you know for the theory cs people in
the audience
this probably looks very you know bread
and butter standard stuff but i
i thought it's important to say this
because for people who are
in the audience who are not you know not
in cs in other areas
this is not something that i think you
think about all the time or
maybe i've even seen before um but good
so
so that you know this is this is one of
the things that goes into
unidealizing the algorithm
is basically realizing that and you know
you don't really need a truly random
function
as long as your function is it comes
from a two wise independent family
i can analyze my algorithm and show that
it still works um it still gives the
desired you know
behavior okay
oh i've created the maximum number
whiteboard so i guess i need to start
recycling so let's go back to the
beginning
and let's erase this
okay so here's an um actually in fact
see something
good so i this is where i was i wanted
to give you one non-idealized algorithm
so let's do that
so non-idealized
so the first observation of this
algorithm is
you know if i promised you that
if i promised you that the number of
distinct elements
is at most k for some k
then you know there's a very simple
algorithm that uses k log n bits of
memory
namely i'll just explicitly store
the first k distinct things i see or the
first and most kissing things i see
and you know once i see more than k
distinct things
i'll just you know give up and fail i'll
just say okay you know what i
i can't do it anymore so
so let's say there's a parameter k
if there are at most k distinct elements
you can output the answer exactly
using basically k log n bits of memory
just like store them explicitly
so with this observation in hand here's
here's an algorithm
i'll pick a random function h
that maps uh let's say n into n
and i from a two wise family and let's
pretend that n is a power of two
which i can do by just rounding up
okay so remember now that this means i
can store this h in log
n bits right k log n bits k is two so
two log n bits so
log n bits and
let's call this um
[Music]
let's call this data structure here so
this this i'm going to
call a data structure it's a very simple
data structure it's a data structure
that solves the distinct elements
problem
in the in the case that the answer is
less than k
or at most k it'll solve it exactly so
let me call this thing
the simple data structure
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
instantiate a bunch of these simple data
structures
we'll pick k later but we'll have data
structure
you know simple simple one
simple two all the way down to
simple login
so we have log n copies of this data
structure
and we have this hash function h
which maps n into n
and now how do i process an update
when i see h when i see um so if someone
says update i
i'll compute h of i so i see i in the
stream i'll compute
h of i right and what is h of i
it's some number which i'll write in
binary
and what i'll do is i'll look at the
index of the least significant bit
so here it's right here this is the
starting from the right it's the first
time that i have a bit which is non-zero
so these are the indices this is index
one two three four et cetera so
the least significant bit here is in
index three
so sorry i did one base indexing here
this is index three
so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna take
this i
so there's a simple three that's right
here
i'm going to take this i and i'm going
to send it
into simple three right y3 it's the same
it's this three right this three is the
same as this three
the r it's the fact that the least
significant bit of the hash was in the
third location means i'm gonna send it
to symbol three
okay so why am i doing this well
how many distinct elements do i expect
get mapped into simple one t over two
right remember there are two distinct
elements i don't know t
t over two are going to get mapped into
simple one and expectation
two over four are going to get mapped to
simple two t over eight are going to get
mapped to symbol three right
so an expectation
t over two to the k gets sent into
simple k
okay let me not
you know spend the labor and you know
and
and write down all the math behind uh
the analysis it's not very
it's ultimately it's just chebyshev's
inequality but here's the
here's kind of the idea of why this
thing works okay
so ultimately what i'm going to do is
i'm going to set k
to be you know like some constant times
1 over epsilon squared
now how many
distinct elements get mapped to the
bottom simple simple log n
it's t over two to the n so t over n
so t over two to the log n so t over n
um so unless t is large unless t is like
on the order of n
probably nothing gets mapped into simple
log n right so if i look at simple log n
it's going to tell me there are no
distinct elements and if i look at one
level
higher it's probably also going to tell
me there are no distinct elements
right working my way from the bottom to
the top it's basically going to say 0 0
0 0 until until i get to
until i get to a k such that
t over two to the k is you know a
constant
right once i get to such a k
then um
i'm starting i'm gonna start to see a
non-zero number of distinct elements at
that level
so already that k gives me some kind of
constant approximation
right to t basically i know that t is
roughly within a constant
equal to 2 to the k
now that i know what t is up to roughly
some constant factor
i want to hone in and not just get a
constant factor but i want a one plus
epsilon approximation
what i'll do is i'll zoom in on the
level
where i know that you know t over 2 to
the k
is some constant but i don't know the
constant
actually let me write it like this i'll
i'll hone in on a level where t
over two to the k i know is sandwiched
between
some constant c2 times one over epsilon
squared
and some constant c1 times one over
epsilon squared
these are just this is just k right so
basically let me say i should just say k
okay and but i do
you know what so i know that i know that
i expect t over to the k to be between
these
so i hone in on that level oh sorry i
just realized i'm
i used k in two different ways right
this t over to the k is approximately
one
sorry this uh it's better just because k
is k is the parameter of the simple data
structure
so let me not call this k let me let me
call this um
l for level
okay so i hit i hone in on the level l
such that t over two to the l in
expectation is s
is theta k so i know that standards
between c one k and c two k
but i don't know it up till one plus
epsilon
so what i do is i just look at that
level i look at simple l
and i just see how many distinct
elements were there in the level simple
l
okay and if i just scale that number
back up by two to the l
first of all you know the the the number
of items that land there will be the
expectation
plus or minus the standard deviation
with constant probability
and the expectation you know by design
the expectation is on the order of k
so the standard deviation is on the
order of root k
right so i i expect an additive error in
the number of people who actually map
there randomly under h
to be on the order of root k
but you know if the expectation is is
roughly k
then having an additive error of root k
is the same thing as having a
multiplicative error of one plus epsilon
by our choice of k right we chose k to
be one of epsilon squared so this
additive error root k is basically a
multiplicative error of one plus epsilon
so if i take that number that i actually
see and i scale back up by two to the l
with good probability i'll actually have
the true value of t
up to a multiplicative error of one plus
epsilon
okay and to argue that
the additive error ic is the standard
deviation it's this additive plus or
minus root k
i argue that via chebyshev's inequality
chubby chev's inequality only depends on
variance and variance only depends on
the second moment right i mean that's
what variance is it's a second moment
so i just need to have two wise
independents in my hash
function as long as my hash function is
from a two y's independent family
my variance will be as if it were from a
truly random hash function h
and that's where i'm able to get away
with the pseudorandomness in my hash
function because i only need a variance
bound
okay um so i know i didn't get i know i
didn't give you the you know
write down all the details of the
calculations but that's basically the
gist of it
what's the space here um i need to store
h that's one
thing that's log n bits okay so h is log
in bits to store
i need to store log n copies of the
simple data structure
each simple data structure takes k log n
bits
so that's k log squared n and k is one
over epsilon
squared so in total in total what i've
used
oh i've used the maximum white boards
let's claim a new whiteboard again this
can be another whiteboard
and i got almost out of time so in total
i've used
k times log squared n which is
1 over epsilon squared log squared n
bits
if i wanted failure probability delta
this would give me some constant failure
probability
i could just repeat this data structure
in parallel log one over delta times
and then output the median that would
give me
one over epsilon squared log squared and
log one over delta bits
the truth
is that the the complexity of this
problem
upper and lower bounds is one over
epsilon squared log
one over delta plus log n bits
and the upper bound is due to your swab
washic
and this is the upper bound and the
lower bound
is due to david woodruff and o4
as well as alone matias and sagitty
so the loan master's in society showed
that log n is a lower bound david
woodruff showed that
um oh he showed that one of us on
squared is lower bound if you also want
the log one or delta i believe that you
all you need to use something from
jram woodruff
i forget the year
and this is this is for the lower bound
okay um good so
i'm not going to have time i'm not going
to show you this this
particular upper bound but it does use
the similar idea of you know this gm you
know geometrically
decreasing levels um
and you know somehow getting in you know
zooming in at the right level
to get a good to refine your estimate of
your of your uh
to refine your approximation to one plus
epsilon um
so good that took that so just the upper
bounds like a full hour
on monday what i'll do is i'll show you
how to prove lower bounds and then we're
going to move on to you know
a larger class of problems that we're
going to study monday tuesday and
wednesday
and so i think that's it for my hour any
any um any questions
yeah there is a question that do not
answer you
so what's the prior distribution of the
set of function capital h
i'm not sure what this means oh um
so also so so here i gave this example
of a ky's independent family right which
was like polynomial hashing
so um in the actual algorithm that
you know that i showed you this is the
actual algorithm i said pick an h from a
two eyes family
so for example what you can do is assume
n is a power of two
right so now it is a prime power
and what you could do for example is um
just do ax plus b over that finite field
so your hash function is you pick a
random a you pick a random b
from this finite field which is a field
of size two to the log n
of size n and you just do you know your
polynomial is a linear
polynomial it's a x plus b
does that make sense no
okay well is there still a question
there is another question okay what's
no upper lower bounds for the distance
elements problem
in turn style streams oh and turn style
streams yeah so
that's a good question so first of all
maybe you can explain what is turn style
to the audience
i said this in the beginning that in
turn style in turn style like
you have this vector x which is this
high dimensional vector and you see
these coordinate wise updates like add 5
to x1 subtract 2 from x3 and then now
eventually i want to query
so in the in the version that i'm
showing you now of the distinct elements
problem
i'm only allowed to see items i'm not
allowed to like unsee
i'm not allowed to delete items right so
for example
if i said add one to x1 add one to x5
that's basically saying i saw one in the
stream i saw five in the stream
but then if i say subtract one from x1
that's like someone then later saying
you know what subtract you know delete
one from the stream
so not only do i want to support
insertion of items in the stream i also
want to support deletion of items from
the stream later
does that make sense
so for example you know let's let's let
me give you an example
you know let's say that we're all we're
on some social media site like facebook
okay and um people are fretting each
other and they're actually that's not
that's not a very
good example it's not a good example um
[Music]
okay but you know basically someone can
say insert something
insert you know insert one insert two
insert one delete one so the stream has
a bunch of insertions and deletions
right and now i want to know what's the
support size of x or how many distinct
elements are still in the set
so this would be like a more general
problem where i'm allowed to i'm also
allowed to delete items
right
um so the you know the problem with the
algorithm that i just showed you
the non-idealized algorithm i just
showed you is this simple out you know
this algorithm that i called simple at
the top
it just stores the first k items you saw
the first k distinct items you saw
and once you see more than k items it
just gives up
right but what if
i insert 100k items
and then i delete 99k items you know
what i mean
then i actually have less than k items
right
so the simple out the simple algorithm
won't work because once
once i saw more than k it gave up it did
it didn't take into account that there
could be later deletions of items
um now but in any case there it there is
there is an algorithm that solves the
version even with deletions in fact
there's a way to implement the simple
data structure and in fact we're going
to talk about that later when i talk
about
representing graphs as high dimensional
vectors and sketching graphs
there's basically a way to solve exactly
the same problem as the simple problem
what the simple problem is solving even
when there are deletions so as long as
at query time there are less than k
distinct elements
let's say i wanted i want to be able to
answer the question
right even even if in intermediate steps
i have more than k items as long as that
query time i have under k
i want to be able to answer it that
turns out to be a solvable problem
okay with some with some low memory data
structure
um in fact it'll use something like k
log squared n bits instead of k log n
bits
so there's an extra log n that enters
the space complexity
to be able to support these deletions
and in fact that's optimal
but in terms of um if you want to
support deletions
with deletions um
so if you look at this paper by
uh daniel kane myself
and david woodruff this was in 2010
we could show that it's um you could get
a bound that's like 1 over epsilon
squared times log n
i believe it's something like times
maybe
log log n plus log one or epsilon if i
remember correctly
and um there and there is a there's a
lower bound that either
matches this or comes very close to
matching this i know that
i know that we also had a lower bound in
the same paper we had a lower bound of
sorry
we had a lower bound of this in our
paper but there was a later paper by
david woodruff and another co-author who
i'm forgetting right now that i think
that i think showed that even even this
part needs to be there
um any other questions
yeah so if there are more questions then
you can either just type into the
uh the q a or you can simply unmute
yourself and ask
uh july yep so how do you
zoom in i mean how do you choose the
like highest
bucket like is it the first one that
reports
that uh there's something there or does
there have to be like a lot of items
there before you believe it
so like for example this one yeah i said
i said i said for you so this this red
area that i circled right here
this part yeah so
if you just go if even if you just use
the first
like the deepest the deepest uh simple
data structure
that has something non-zero you can
prove that that
that'll that already will be some
constant factor approximation with you
know decent probability
you don't need to wait until you have a
few items even just having one is enough
okay i mean it'll be a pretty bad
constant in terms of like what is your
constant factor of approximation but
it'll be
it's a constant and just having some
constant is is good enough to be able to
then
you know zoom in here later
cool any other questions
i i have like a naive question is it
important that you
know n the cap on the number of distinct
elements
so here yeah so n here is like the
universe that they're coming from
so like yeah so is it is it important to
know that in advance
um yeah so you're saying what if i don't
know the i don't know have any
information about the universe they're
coming from that's your question right
yeah i guess i mean in the online
setting
um
so i guess maybe to say your question or
just say your question back so for
example each item i see in the str
in the stream is a string and these
strings can be of like unbounded length
so i don't have any a priori
knowledge of of like a bound on the
size of the universe right um
and i also let's say don't have any kind
of bound on the stream length
then i'm not so um i'm not sure
i'm not sure what the answer to that
would be
okay any other question
if not let's uh thank you for a nice
thought and they will continue
uh next monday uh we are done for this
for this week right lately yeah thank
you so much johnny